Is the French Communist Party extreme left?
No,
should we eat
less meat
to fight against global warming?
Yes,
we need to help immigrants more
to arrive in France ?
Yes,
is the USSR a model?
Yeah,
does Mélenchon have the stature of a president of the
Republic? No,
Europeans are politicizing too much.
Yes.
Should France leave the European Union?
No,
should the communist party get out of the upps?
Wow! No,
nupc brother,
it is a legislative agreement,
so the member will stay.
Should Ukraine join the European Union
immediately? From Europe.
The European Treaties
must they remain above French laws
of Europe?
The
communist party wants
impose the dictatorship of the?
Of course,
are renewable energies more reliable
than nuclear?
No,
Léon de fontaine on 1 European epito site.
Indeux-mille-vingt-quatre,
it's obvious.
Is Roussel the best candidate for the left?
Indeux-mille-vingt-sept,
it's obvious. The treat.